économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
chargé des comptes publics sur le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023
j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo qui sera
retransmée en direct sur le site du
Sénat et disponible en vidéo à la
demande elle sera aussi l'occasion
d'évoquer le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques que
nous examinerons pour avis demain matin
en commission même si nous peinons
quelque peu pour le moment apercevoir la
cohérence des deux textes dans le grand
dessin du gouvernement pour les finances
publiques
monsieur le ministreur ne faisait pas
mystère de son souhait de voir
disparaître le PLFSS au profit d'un seul
et même texte budgétaire argon qu'il
s'agissait je cite de la même poche
c'est un débat qui n'est pas nouveau
c'est bien sûr une position nous pouvons
pas partager notre commission n'a jamais
été d'accord sur ce point-là mais s'il a
un point sur lequel nous souhaitons
ardemment un alignement c'est celui de
la qualité et du format des informations
transmises cette année encore vos
services sont consacrés beaucoup
d'énergie à la préparation du rapport de
la commission des Condens de la sécurité
sociale dans la réunion s'est tenue
après la présentation du PLFSS sans pour
autant en intégrer les données et dans
le même temps alors que nous examinerons
le PLFSS en commission de la semaine
prochaine
votre ministère et nous le regrettons
n'a pu tirer les conséquences de
l'article
au
111-4-5 du code de la sécurité sociale
issue de la loi organique du 14 mars
dernier qui prévoit que les données
chiffres et utilisées pour les tableaux
graphiques contenus sont publiés sous
forme électronique dans un standard
ouvert aisément réutilisables
exploitables par un système de
traitement automatisé ces données sont
pourtant présentes dans le rapport
économique social et financier annexé au
projet de loi de finances j'ai adressé
un courrier en ce sens afin d'unifier
les deux textes vous l'aurez compris
nous appelons rapprochement des méthodes
le PLFSS ne pouvant rester plus
longtemps le lieu de l'approximation et
de la Convention
voilà après ces propos liminaires
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
et nous disposons d'une heure ensuite
les rapporteurs vous posant les
questions et nos collègues à suivre
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur général Mesdames et Messieurs
les sénatrices et sénateurs je suis très
heureux d'être avec vous aujourd'hui
pour l'examen pour l'audition sur le
PLFSS 2023 je vous le dis d'emblée pour
répondre à la question que vous aviez
posée sur position sur le PLFSS je suis
attaché au PLFSS et un texte spécifique
je pense que c'est très important pour
la clarté des débats certes il n'y a
qu'un seul contribuable au goût il faut
toujours le rappeler et c'est vrai que
parfois dans certains débats
certains font mines de l'oublier mais je
pense que c'est très important de
d'avoir une forme de clarté sur
l'ambition qui est la nôtre les moyens
qu'on nous consacrons à notre système de
santé et aux médico-social et je vous
prie de m'excuser en tout cas je
présente mes excuses si l'ensemble des
données en tout cas dans la forme qui
est prévue par la nouvelle loi organisme
on l'organique relative aux lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale ne
sont pas arrivés dans les temps c'est
vrai que à partir de cette année on
inaugure une nouvelle LOLF SS
ce qui impose ce qui imposait beaucoup
de travail pour les services des
différents ministères et je veux saluer
évidemment la Direction de la Sécurité
sociale la direction générale de l'offre
de soins la direction du budget
également et la DGCS qui ont beaucoup
travaillé avec un calendrier qui est
plus contraint que les années
précédentes nous sommes donc réunis pour
aborder ces enjeux majeurs pour répondre
au fond aux aspirations des Français je
crois que leur aspiration est simple
préserver un système social auquel ils
sont profondément attachés mais ils ont
déplore encore trop souvent les failles
les inégalités ou les incohérences et
nous appartient évidemment d'y répondre
notre défi c'est donc de bâtir ensemble
un système plus accessible plus efficace
et plus juste un système plus accessible
c'est d'abord améliorer l'accès aux
soins les formes ne débutent pas
aujourd'hui depuis 2017 nous avons
investi 53 milliards euros de plus dans
notre système de santé avec un nom d'âme
qui est passé de 191 milliards d'euros
en 2017 à 244 milliards d'euros en 2023
nous avons mis fin au baisse de tarifs
hospitaliers déployer le 100% santé
supprimé le numerus clausus soutenu le
secteur de l'aide à domicile et nos
EHPAD nous allons poursuivre cet effort
conformément aux engagements que nous
avons pris devant les Français voilà
pourquoi avec ce PLFSS londam
progressera en 2023 à un niveau
historique de
3,7%, c'est une progression 50% plus
rapide que dans la décennie 2010 pour la
dame hospitalier l'augmentation sera de
4,1% en 2023 ces deux fois plus qu'au
cours de la décennie 2010 ou le rythme
moyen pour l'ONDAM hospitalier était de
2% 2% dans la décennie 2010 4,1% en 2023
j'entends les débats sur l'inflation
mais nous avons précisément tenu compte
des besoins exprimés par les fédérations
hospitalières et avec mon collègue
François Braun après
dissertation nous avons ouvert une
enveloppe exceptionnelle de 800 millions
d'euros en 2022 et de 800 millions
d'euros supplémentaires en 2023 elle
permettra de couvrir les effets de
l'inflation sur les achats hospitaliers
qui s'ajoutent évidemment au financement
intégral de l'augmentation du point
d'indice je dis cela parce que j'ai pu
entendre dans certains débats politiques
que quand bien même nous aurions un
niveau historique dondames le fait qu'il
est sous le niveau de l'inflation
projeté en 2023 constituerait selon
certains en réalité une baisse bah non
l'inflation n'a pas un impact sur
l'ensemble des dépenses de santé elle a
un impact très fort sur un certain
nombre de dépenses notamment les achats
hospitaliers c'est pour ça que nous
prévoyons des enveloppes dédiées mais on
ne peut pas tirer un trait égal entre
l'inflation et un impact qu'elle aurait
globalement sur le long terme renforcer
l'accès aux soins c'est aussi vrai être
meilleur prise en charge pour nous aînés
en situation de dépendance avec un
mandat médico-social à plus 5,1% en 2023
nous finançons le plan effet des
augmentations de salaire la
médicalisation des EHPAD et l'embauche
de milliers de soignants supplémentaires
et l'investissement renforcés pour les
services à domicile nous sommes
évidemment pas du tout encore au bout du
chemin il nous faudra poursuivre ce
renforcement des moyens dans les années
à venir là aussi j'entends les débats
faut-il une loi spécifique au grand âge
vous avez auditionné mon collègue
Jean-Christophe combe notamment sur ce
sujet et je rappelle que l'ensemble des
augmentations salariales décidées depuis
la crise sanitaire représente un effort
de 3,2 milliards d'euros par an pour la
cinquième branche que nous avons créé en
2021 nous agissons aussi pour faciliter
l'accès au mode de garde parce que nous
savons combien le destin de nos enfants
se joue dès les 1000 premiers jours
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
engageons avec ce PLFSS la première
pierre d'un véritable service public de
la petite enfance conformément aux
engagements du Président de la
République nous réduisons drastiquement
le reste à charge des familles pour le
recours aux assistants maternels
concrètement une maman seule au SMIC
économisera 200 euros avec la réforme du
complément mode de garde prévu à
l'article 36 de ce PLF un couple de
classe moyenne qui confie son enfant
pour 40 50 heures par semaine
économisera près de 2000 euros sur
l'année c'est du très concret pour des
milliers de familles mais tous ces
progrès ne sont possibles que si nous
continuons à donner la priorité au
travail et à la production les
cotisations demeurent le socle du
financement de notre sécurité sociale
elles vont progresser de 391 milliards
d'euros en 2022 à 407 milliards d'euros
en 2023 et nous le devons d'abord aux
créations d'emplois 310000 sont prévus
en 2022 nous en avons déjà réalisé 220
000 au premier semestre et 117 000
supplémentaires sont attendus aux 2023
ce qui signifie qu'au total sur la
période 2020 2023 malgré le retour de
l'inflation et la crise notre pays
devrait avoir créé un million 200000
emplois n'oublions jamais que c'est le
travail qui tient notre système social
voilà pourquoi ce PLFSS entend aussi
rendre notre système social plus
efficace parce que les besoins sont nous
ne devons ménager aucun effort pour
trouver des marges déficiences et oui
pour réaliser des économies là où elles
sont pertinentes faire de la politique
c'est faire des choix construire un
budget c'est faire des choix politiques
c'est pourquoi nous assumons de demander
des efforts à certains secteurs qui
peuvent contribuer à l'effort commun
nous assumons de demander des efforts au
laboratoire de biologie qui ont réalisé
un chiffre d'affaires de 7,3 milliards
d'euros au titre des tests covid en 2020
et 2021 je veux dire qu'ils ont été des
acteurs très importants de la lutte
contre l'épidémie qu'ils ont été
absolument indispensables à la politique
de test que nous avons engagé et
personne ne remet en cause ce rôle
absolument essentiel mais la réalité
c'est qu'il y a eu 7,3 milliards d'euros
de profits en tout cas de chiffre
d'affaires liés au test qu'il y avait
une rentabilité élevée pour le secteur
déjà avant la crise et ce PLFSS prévoit
donc à l'article 27 que la CNAM
négociera une baisse de prix avec le
secteur pour au moins 250 millions gros
dès 2023 par les deux chiffres on voit
que c'est un effort qui évidemment reste
mesuré il y a bientôt 10 ans en 2013 un
rapport d'information du Sénat fait au
nom de votre commission souligné déjà je
cite que les efforts déficients du
secteur et de régulation de la dépense
sont insuffisants le dernier ralphèses
de la Cour des Comptes publié début
octobre rappelle que cette ambition de
réguler la dépense sans remettre en
cause la qualité des soins reste
d'actualité nous assumons aussi demander
des efforts au secteur de l'imagerie
médicale qui représente près de 5
milliards d'euros de dépenses et où nous
pouvons limiter les examens redondants
inappropriés ou inutile là aussi en
cohérence avec les recommandations
formulées par les experts de la Cour des
comptes mais aussi par le Sénat qui
souligna dans un rapport de 2016 le
travail nécessaire de pertinence des
actes à conduire avec la Haute Autorité
de santé nous demandons à ce secteur de
négocier avec la CNAM un nouveau
protocole pour juguler la dépense de 150
millions d'euros en 2023 nous assumons
de demander des efforts à l'industrie du
médicament car nous devons redoubler
l'effort pour la pertinence des
prescriptions la baisse des prix ciblés
sur les médicaments les plus anciens
pour dans le même temps mieux
récompenser l'innovation ces baisses de
prix s'élèveront à 800 millions d'euros
en 2023 j'ai entendu là aussi beaucoup
de choses sur ce sujet nous avons dans
le cadre de l'examen à l'Assemblée
nationale adopter un certain nombre
d'amendements qui permettent je crois de
rassurer sur ce point et sur le fait
évidemment nous serons dans la lignée
des engagements pris par le Président de
la République devant le 6 et toujours au
rendez-vous pour financer l'innovation
dans notre pays enfin nous assumons
demander des efforts aux organismes
complémentaires dont la part dans le
financement des dépenses de santé baisse
tendentiellement il y a 10 ans elle
finançait 15,5% des dépenses de santé
quand elle n'en financé plus que 12,9%
en 2021 nous devons donc réfléchir à un
juste partage de l'effort avec la
sécurité sociale et mon collègue
François Braun a ouvert des
concertations
dans ce sens ces efforts nous ne les
demandons pas et j'insiste sur ce point
par plaisir de faire des économies nous
les demandons parce qu'ils sont
indispensables pour dégager des marges
de manœuvre budgétaires et investir en
priorité à l'hôpital et dans le
médico-social ces efforts sont aussi la
condition pour garantir la soutenabilité
et la résilience de nos comptes sociaux
à un moment au prédomine l'incertitude
économique comment témoignent la
remontée de nos taux d'intérêt la
parenthèse de l'argent gratuit et
derrière nous on en prend plus à taux
négatif ou à tonul nous empruntons à des
taux qui sont sensiblement remontés ce
qui nécessite évidemment de redoubler
d'efforts dans la maîtrise de nos
dépenses enfin nous voulons avec ce
PLFSS construire un système social plus
juste cela passe par des mesures que
présente mon collègue Jean-Christophe
combe sur les familles monoparentales
plus souvent frappés par la pauvreté
mais assurer la justice c'est aussi
adresser un message de fermeté à l'égard
de tous les fraudeurs il s'agisse de la
fraude au cotisations ou de la fraude
aux prestations frauder c'est voler
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
ferons preuve de la plus grande fermeté
à l'égard de tous ceux qui en fraudant
ou en abusant le système abîme
l'adhésion des Français à notre modèle
social et nous portons plusieurs mesures
dans ce PLFSS des pouvoirs de cyber
enquête sont confiés à plus de 400
contrôleur des caisses de sécurité
sociale pour mieux repérer et réprimer
les fraudes à enjeu c'est l'article 41
de ce texte les facultés de
déconventionnement seront étendues à
tous les professionnels de santé en cas
de fraude majeur grâce à l'article 42
les échanges d'informations seront
renforcés notamment entre les greffiers
des tribunaux de commerce et les caisses
de sécurité sociale pour mieux lutter
contre le travail informel les fraudeurs
paieront désormais des frais de gestion
pour financer la détection et le
recouvrement des indus frauduleux parce
que les Français ne supportent plus de
financer par leurs impôts le traitement
des dossiers de fraudeur
nous interdirons par ailleurs le
versement de prestations sociales hors
pension sur des comptes bancaires qui ne
seraient pas situés en France ou en zone
sépa dès lors que les prestations en
question sont soumises à condition de
résidence sur notre territoire c'était
une proposition là aussi qui a été
portée au Sénat notamment par la
sénatrice Nathalie Goulet dont j'ai pu
voir sur Twitter qu'elle m'en avait
beaucoup voulu de ne pas l'avoir citer
quand j'ai présenté cet amendement à
l'Assemblée nationale et donc évidemment
je la cite ici à la conduit un travail
très dense sur ce sujet là et donc ça
vaudra pour la SPA les prestations
familiales le RSA ou encore la location
supplémentaire d'invalidité à nouveau un
rapport du Sénat en 2020 soulignait que
sur l'ASPA par exemple près de la moitié
des fraudes étaient imputables au
non-respect de la condition de résidence
je crois d'ailleurs que c'est son
rapport enfin nous ferons reculer les
abus d'arrêt maladie prescrits en
téléconsultation on ne prenant en charge
que ce prescrit par le médecin traitant
ou par un médecin déjà consulté au cours
des 12 derniers mois
enfin car je sais que sur ce sujet aussi
le Sénat a beaucoup travaillé et produit
un rapport vous voyez comme nous sommes
attentifs aux propositions portées par
les sénatrices et les sénateurs je
souhaite vous indiquer que le texte sur
lequel le gouvernement engagé sa
responsabilité à l'Assemblée sur la
troisième partie du PLFSS retient un
amendement sur le transfert agir Carco
transfert du recouvrement des
cotisations de la jrco à la COS sur ce
sujet beaucoup d'encre a déjà coulé je
veux rappeler ici quelques points
premièrement l'amendement présenté par
le gouvernement répond précisément à la
recommandation de la mission
d'évaluation et de contrôle de la
sécurité sociale et de votre commission
c'était le rapport Savary a poursu poli
puisque nous reportons à 2024 le
transfert aux URSSAF du recouvrement des
cotisations de retraite complémentaires
et que nous clarifions la répartition
des responsabilités entre l'agir Carco
et les urssafs c'était aussi la demande
des syndicats et du patronat nous y
répondons favorablement
deuxièmement l'amendement demande à la
JR Carco et aux URSSAF de conclure
rapidement une convention pour un style
inscrire ce partage de responsabilité
noire sur blanc soyons clairs le métier
des urssafs c'est de recouvrer pas de
verser les retraites ni aujourd'hui ni
demain les urssafs ne verseront les
retraites complémentaires et la Gère
Carco conservera évidemment un rôle
primordial pour fiabiliser les données
individuelles des salariés concernant
leurs droits retraite complémentaire
c'est ce que traduire à cette convention
enfin je rappelle pourquoi nous faisons
ce transfert qui s'inscrit dans le
projet plus large du gouvernement
d'unifier le recouvrement social aux
urssafs et le recouvrement fiscal à la
DGFiP c'est un enjeu de simplification
pour les entreprises pour leur démarche
avec un interlocuteur unique c'est aussi
un objectif de gain de recouvrement pour
le régime de la jerk Arrco lui-même
si nous parvenons à améliorer ne
serait-ce que d'un demi point le taux de
recouvrement comme nous l'avons fait
pour d'autres transferts et d'autres
recouvrements qui ont été transférés aux
urssafs ces dernières années ce sont des
centaines de millions d'euros de plus
collectés au bénéfices de l'agirco
c'est-à-dire au bénéfice des salariés
mesdames Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs au cours de nos débats en
commission puis en séance nous allons
enrichir ensemble ce PLFSS quel que soit
vos opinions vos bords politiques
l'origine et votre département
d'élection je crois que chacune et
chacun d'entre vous ont un rôle à jouer
dans la refondation de notre système
social au fond chacun d'entre vous
chacun d'entre nous souhaite un système
plus simple plus efficace et plus juste
alors faisons de ce PLFSS ensemble un
texte utile aux Français à une époque de
grande bascule à une époque où le fracas
de la guerre revient en Europe ou la
menace du défi climatique et là avec un
risque d'effondrement de la biodiversité
à une époque ou même l'adhésion à notre
modèle social et démocratique menace le
CD nous avons chacune et chacun d'entre
nous une responsabilité immense alors
au-delà des clivages légitimes sachant
bâtir avec confiance et responsabilité
un PLFSS qui sera l'une des briques d'un
pays plus unis et plus solidaire je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
passer tout de suite la parole à
elisabethouano rapporteur général
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Ministre on a pu observer
combien vous étiez inspiré de des
travaux du Sénat et nous en sommes très
heureux simplement je vais commencer par
quelques reproches et je poserai mes
questions ensuite d'abord mes reproches
sont sont les mêmes que
ceux de madame la Présidente en réalité
je n'ai reçu qu'hier les réponses aux
questions que j'avais posées et les
réponses sont partielles voir souvent
elliptiques et donc c'est demain que
nous étudierons le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques et
voyez nous sommes vraiment vraiment
un peu un peu gêné par surtout la
légèreté des réponses et puis il en est
de même pour la mise à disposition comme
le disait madame la Présidente
du format exploitable des données
chiffrées qui ont servi à l'élaboration
des annexes notamment l'annexe B du
PLFSS et c'est prévu par la loi
organique comme vous j'espère que les
années qui viennent seront plus plus en
tout cas qu'elle répondront plus
rapidement à nos à nos besoins utiles
parce que les comptes c'est pas
approximatif on a besoin de donner
fiable et importantes en fait ce PLFSS
présenté par vous monsieur le ministre
est tout à fait séduisant en réalité je
le trouve assez paradoxal je vais vous
dire pourquoi en fait pour 2023 on
observe une très nette amélioration du
déficit puisqu'on est à 6,8 milliards
d'euros mais dès 2023 c'est 8,8
milliards d'euros et après ça continue
de baisser à 12 milliards d'euros ça
forme un plateau pendant les années qui
suivent et je trouve que finalement les
comptes se dégradent très vite
je relève alors c'était la première
observation la deuxième c'est finalement
de dire comme le Haut Conseil des
finances publiques qui estiment que les
prévisions sont optimistes oui je
considère qu'elles sont optimistes ne
serait-ce que en regardant cette année
ce qui a été consacré à la crise covid
un milliard d'euros par rapport aux deux
années deux années précédentes bon
certes on n'est pas du tout dans au même
niveau de la crise sanitaire mais
néanmoins je trouve que améliard c'est
court
tout est remboursé en France les tests
jusqu'au vaccin et on sait que voilà les
Français
usent parfois un peu de de consomment je
dirais même tout cela et un milliard
c'est un petit peu un petit peu juste
ça concerne aussi et la croissance des
recettes et la croissance finalement des
dépenses j'ai regardé attentivement les
tableaux et je trouve que l'évolution
aussi plus réelle de lambda mais dans un
contexte inflationniste vous avez fait
quelques précisions là-dessus mais je
trouve que c'est c'est regarder avec un
œil optimiste alors moi je veux bien je
suis plutôt optimiste de nature mais je
trouve que là ce n'est pas très prudent
face à cela je pense que le Sénat et sa
commission des affaires sociales
souhaiteront se donner les moyens de
tenir les objectifs financiers afficher
et de contrôler qu'il n'y ait pas de
dérive des comptes sans retour au
Parlement l'année prochaine c'était tout
l'objet d'ailleurs des demandes qui ont
été fait dans la loi organique
pour le moment j'aurais quelques
questions simples donc à vous poser à la
fois sur le PLFSS et aussi marginalement
sur justement le projet de programmation
des finances publiques que nous
étudierons demain sur quelques
articles sur le pour avis première
question pourriez-vous nous préciser
l'impact financier en recettes et en
dépense associée à une éventuelle
réforme des retraites pour chaque année
de la programmation de 2023 2026 oui
c'est la première question c'est la plus
aride je le reconnais mais quand on
regarde l'annexe B euh voilà on se dit
mais il est tenu d'une réforme mais on
en connaît finalement ni les paramètres
ni les effets et pourtant il en est tenu
compte donc voilà ma première question
c'est celle là je désolé
comme
la deuxième question est-ce que vous
pourriez faire un point sur les
transferts à la caddesse qui doivent
encore être effectués au titre de la loi
de 2020 en fait si mes collègues se
souviennent des tableaux justement des
déficits on voit très très vite que
finalement les 92 milliards d'euros
seront atteints avec les défis de que
j'ai rappelé tout à l'heure et donc
qu'est-ce que vous comptez faire
monsieur le ministre pour une nouvelle
loi ou en tout cas qu'est-ce qu'on fait
il y aura certainement plus de
transferts à faire puisqu'on voit très
très bien que les déficits sont plus
importants donc c'était la deuxième
question la troisième pourriez-vous
préciser si une non-adaptation une non
adoption de la loi de programmation des
finances publiques oui je reviens sur
effectivement ces travaux de demain en
fait serait susceptible remettre en
cause
les le financement par l'Union
européenne de 6 milliards d'euros pour
les investissements du quotidien en fait
c'est vrai que cette loi de
programmation des finances publiques on
se pose toujours la question pas adopter
à l'Assemblée nationale peut-être
adopter avec quelques changements au
Sénat mais si elle n'est pas adoptée
qu'est-ce qui se passe et il y a
notamment ces 6 milliards de roues qui
sont suspendus à la vie de l'Union
européenne voilà donc quatrième question
comment juste ici justifier vous le
transfert payant de la branche maladie
bah ça c'est une question qui revient
systématiquement Sénat parce que nous on
avait déjà
comment dirais-je supprimer
cet article de 1 milliard l'année
dernière aujourd'hui c'est 2 milliards
d'euros sur une partie des indemnités
journalières du congé de maternité que
vous allez justement faire prendre en
charge du coup par la branche famille
donc voilà nous on voudrait comment une
justification parce qu'on pas forcément
que c'est judicieux enfin la réforme de
la fiscalité du tabac poursuit-elle
uniquement un objectif de rendement
sinon quel est votre objectif en termes
de diminution de la consommation on le
voit très bien dans beaucoup de pays dès
lors que la fiscalité du tabac augmenté
il est en proportion suffisante parce
que là c'est pas beaucoup c'est je crois
0,70 centimes d'euros par un paquet de
tabac cigarette c'est pas beaucoup mais
quand on a une vraie hausse on diminue
la consommation de tabac après je sais
bien c'est pas politiquement correct ici
mais moi je veux le dire à titre
personnel on fait subir l'inflation au
tabac
on subit l'inflation sur le pas sur tous
nos aliments et on fait pas subir
l'inflation sur le vin et ça ça me gêne
enfin sur l'alcool je sais bien que
c'est pas politiquement correct ici mais
en termes de santé publique en terme de
santé publique je voudrais rappeler mes
collègues que le chasseur à la sortie
plus de ravages que le tabac et que
c'est un vrai problème si on voulait
baisser les dépenses d'assurance maladie
et bien regardons les chiffres des
ravages de l'alcool voilà merci
la nouvelle conclusion ensuite on prend
les questions d'autres à suivre c'est
comme vous voulez mettre c'est pour vous
il y a pas énormément de questions dans
les on prend philippouiller les
rapporteurs et puis ensuite tu vois
merci le ministre je vais commencer tout
d'abord par trois questions que je vais
poser pour le compte de
rapporteur pour la l'assurance maladie
alors Monsieur ministre donc je souhaite
naturellement vous interroger donc plus
précisément sur la soutenabilité
financière de l'assurance maladie sur la
trajectoire premièrement le pvss nous
donne une trajectoire de redressement
rapide des comptes alors qu'il y a un an
à peine le directeur de la CNAM lui-même
estimait que 10 ans de déficit important
s'annonçait pour la branche or les
mesures particulières comme le transfert
du remboursement du congé maternité
post-natal ne semble pas suffire à
expliquer ce redressement financier ma
question simple faut-il voir dans ce
solde amélioré des mesures de recettes
cachées ou des euphores en dépense
dissimulées
deuxième question
au-delà de la trajectoire donc c'est une
question de porte naturellement sur
l'onde
et dernière question
concernant Corinne Imbert monsieur le
ministre condam dans le cadre du projet
de loi de programmation des finances
publiques actuellement en débat donc ce
projet prévoit une mise en réserve d'au
moins 0,3% des crédits de Damme auront
le sait et la commission d'enquête sur
l'hôpital la souligné l'ONDAM de ville
n'est jamais régulée et c'est de manière
systématiquement hospitalier qui éponge
les dépassements des autres
sous-objectifs cette mise en réserve
a-t-elle un sens dans le contexte que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui et si oui
comment faire que cet objectif de
maîtrise de la dépense ne soit pas
encore une fois le seul fait de
l'hôpital
et j'aurai deux dernières questions
concernant cette fois la branche
autonomie que je rapporte je reviens sur
l'annexe B du PVPs qui indique que la
branche autonomie retrouverait une
situation excédentaire en 2024 donc je
rends 9 milliards sont indiqués en
parallèle des objectifs ambitieux sont
engagés je pense notamment à ce qui
était ce qui est proposé avec la
création de 50000 postes le financement
du temps dédié aux liens social dans ce
contexte lorsqu'on fait les calculs et
bien la question est simple qu'est-ce
qui reste disponible en matière
d'évolution pour les personnes âgées et
quid des personnes handicapées par en
pauvre de ce PDFs aujourd'hui quelle
proposition finalement de nouvelles
recettes pour être portées à cet horizon
pour pouvoir finalement réellement
financer les besoins de notre pays et
puis dernière remarque c'est plutôt une
remarque concernant la loi grand tâche
que vous évoquez vous la présentez avec
une interrogation sur la nécessité
uniquement sous l'angle de financement
ça je mais le principe d'une la grande
tâche c'est aussi un principe de
d'organisation et peut-être même que
l'efficience des moyens publics engagés
en matière médico-social nécessite de se
pencher sur une loi grand âge notamment
en matière d'organisation de silhouette
financement et c'est peut-être là une
bonne piste pour le ministre que vous
êtes
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Ministre merci pour vos
propos
lorsqu'on vous écoute on trouverait
presque le plfs plus cohérent que
lorsqu'on lit le document mais derrière
les propos notre rôle de parlementaire
c'est évidemment de de poser les
questions et de conserver notre esprit
critique je veux saluer d'abord en
matière de complément de mode de garde
le les 6 à 12 ans pour ce qui concerne
les familles monoparentales et
l'augmentation de
50%, partagez avec vous l'ambition sur
le service public de la de la petite
enfance mais relever quand même une
contradiction où vous interrogez sur
cette question
au moment où il y a une volonté
d'afficher une ambition en matière de de
politique de petite enfance et je pense
que c'est une nécessité
en termes d'égalité homme-femme ça sonne
comme une évidence et puis aussi avec ma
collègue Frédéric puissat en nous sommes
en charge de de du projet de loi sur la
réforme de l'assurance chômage on voit
bien que c'est un des principaux freins
retour à l'emploi pour un certain nombre
de personnes donc c'est une vraie
question pour notre société et pour
notre pays seulement la réalité elle
nous rattrape puisque il y a déjà par
exemple 10 000 emplois qui sont non
pourvus sur le mode de garde et on sait
que c'est de la règle des 1 pour 3 à
chaque fois que on crée une place en
crèche trois places en crèche il faut
embaucher une personne et à l'inverse si
on trouve pas une personne on perd trois
places en mode de garde donc c'est une
réalité implacable il y a 20 000
personnes qui doivent partir en retraite
donc
euh entre les 10000 noms pourvu les
20000 de personnes qui doivent partir en
retraite c'est 30000 emplois pour voir
et si on veut créer 200000 places de
mode de garde supplémentaires c'est 70
000 emplois à créer donc vous voyez
l'enjeu vous le savez et est
considérable et parallèlement à ça si la
la branche famille est en bonne santé
avec 2,5 milliards d'excédents plus de 3
bientôt il y a la question de la
ponction comme la forme bien dit
Elisabeth Doisneau alors
ces fonctions sont tellement importantes
que l'excédent devrait diminuer dans les
années à venir à 0,5 milliards et donc
il y a l'évidence là une contradiction
entre l'affichage du d'une ambition et
puis entre ces fonctions répétées sur la
branche famille qui vont faire en sorte
que au moment où on affiche une ambition
la banque family n'a plus les moyens
d'assumer cette ambition et donc comment
vous voyez les choses par rapport à ça
est-ce que cette ponction sur les
indemnités journalières et ponctuelles
annuels est-ce qu'elle sera renouvelée
dans les années prochaines parce que si
elle les renouvelée à l'évidence
l'ambition qui est affichée en termes de
service public de la petite enfance ne
trouvera pas les les moyens de cette
ambition donc voilà la question que je
voulais vous poser en tant que
rapporteur de la banque famille je vous
remercie merci Monsieur le Ministre
beaucoup de questions
réponses à tout ce qui a été évoqué et
avant les questions oui
avant les questions c'était pas une
question mais c'est une observation que
Madame l'a rapporté en général a réalisé
sur le déficit et les prévisions de
déficit il y a une forme d'effets
ciseaux dans la programmation qui est la
nôtre et dans nos prévisions puisque un
point d'inflation supplémentaire dans
notre système social c'est 3 milliards
de dépenses en plus automatiquement du
fait d'indexation d'un grand nombre de
dépenses sociales à l'inflation là où un
point de ma salariale en plus c'est 2
milliards d'euros de recettes et donc
vous avez une forme d'effet ciseaux
c'est vrai qui contribue à dégrader le
solde sur plusieurs années par ailleurs
la dégradation du déficit est largement
tirée aussi par le déficit prévu sur les
retraites liées notamment un nombre
important de départ à la retraite je
crois 700 000 par an dans les années qui
viennent ce qui justifie d'autant plus
une réforme
des retraites pour ce qui est de la
réforme vous avez posé la question du
non pardon une autre réponse à vos
observations sur le milliard d'euros
prévu pour le covid vous avez dit que
c'était peu on a accumulé un certain
nombre de stocks notamment en termes de
vaccin ces derniers mois il y a eu 5
milliards 800 millions d'euros de
dépenses vaccins sur les années 2020
2021 sur un certain nombre d'équipements
aussi on a réalisé un certain nombre de
stocks ce qu'on prévoit c'est 400
millions pour des vaccins l'année
prochaine et 400 millions également sur
les tests si il faut rajouter un peu et
prévoir des dépenses supplémentaires on
le fera mais vraiment il y a eu un
travail très dense qui a été mené pour
avoir une prévision la plus réaliste
possible et évidemment on sera très
vigilant à ce que l'ensemble des
dépenses soit
au rendez-vous si c'est nécessaire sur
les retraites
on a un engagement de campagne du
président de la République qui est un
report progressif de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite à raison de quatre
mois par an à partir de l'été 2023 pour
atteindre les 65 ans au bout de 10 ans
c'est un engagement et c'est une mesure
que nous avions chiffré au moment de la
campagne présidentielle en gain brut à 8
milliards d'euros à plus de 8 milliards
d'euros à horizon 2027 je dis brut
puisque nous avons pris par ailleurs un
certain nombre d'engagements le
relèvement du minimum contributif à 1000
euros pour tous ceux qui ont une
carrière complète
1100 euros pardon un certain nombre de
mesures d'accompagnement pour ceux qui
ont une carrière pénible ce qui fait que
ce sont des dépenses supplémentaires et
qu'à la fin le gain net et évidemment
pas le même je veux insister aussi sur
un point c'est le gain indirect d'une
réforme des retraites si on propose une
réforme des retraites c'est évidemment
pour améliorer l'équilibre de notre
système de retraite mais c'est aussi
pour améliorer le taux d'emploi dans
notre pays ce qui finance par ailleurs
ensuite des cotisations sociales et des
recettes fiscales supplémentaires on a
eu une étude très intéressante qui vient
de nous être remise par la direction
générale du Trésor qui chiffre entre 15
et 20 milliards d'euros de recettes
sociales et fiscales supplémentaires à
horizon 2027 lié à un recul de l'âge
légal de départ contrairement à ce qu'on
peut entendre ou lire ici ou là
reporter l'âge légal de départ ne se
traduit pas par une diminution du taux
d'emploi des seniors au contraire et
toutes les études qui ont été réalisées
sur la réforme de 2010 non non toutes
les études qui ont été réalisées sur la
réforme de 2010 ont montré que cette
réforme c'était suivi d'une amélioration
du taux d'emploi des seniors plus de 10
points sur 10 ans c'est notre souhait à
tous ce qu'on veut c'est améliorer le
taux d'emploi dans notre pays si je
devais résumer les choses je dirais que
si on avait le taux d'emploi de nos
voisins allemands j'aurais moins de
travail en termes de ministre du Budget
pour chercher à équilibrer nos comptes
c'est quand même la réalité et j'ai
commencé mon intervention en disant que
c'est le travail qui finance notre
système social et les cotisations
notamment plus vous avez de Français qui
travaillent plus vous avez de
financement pour notre système social et
par ailleurs pour nos finances publiques
via des recettes fiscales donc il faut
améliorer le taux d'emploi on l'améliore
en agissant pour l'emploi des jeunes
c'est ce qu'on fait avec l'apprentissage
c'est ce qu'on fait avec la formation
c'est ce qu'on fait avec le plan jeune
une solution on la met on l'améliore
aussi en travaillant sur l'emploi des
seniors c'est un des éléments de la
réforme des retraites et par ailleurs il
y a d'autres actions qui sont engagées
pour améliorer l'emploi des seniors avec
tout ce qui est développé en matière de
formation sur
le CPF sur le plan d'investissement dans
les compétences pour améliorer la
formation les reconversions il y a
beaucoup de progrès qui ont été faits
par ailleurs ces dernières années on a
un taux d'emploi des seniors qui est
beaucoup trop faible en France par
rapport à nos voisins et il faut aussi
regarder les améliorations qu'on a connu
ces dernières années il est aujourd'hui
le taux de chômage des seniors est deux
fois moins élevé que celui des jeunes et
on a connu une amélioration encore ces
dernières années il y a beaucoup de
grandes entreprises qui s'engagent sur
le sujet il faut évidemment poursuivre
sur des transferts à la CADES l'article
17 du PLFSS fixe à 17,7 milliards
d'euros l'objectif d'amortissement de la
dette sociale de la CADES en 2023 la
dette restant amortir devrait s'élever à
154,9 milliards d'euros début 23 c'est
donc un total de 241,6 milliards d'euros
déjà amortis par la cadèse depuis sa
création je rappelle que la loi du 7
août 2020 autorisé un transfert de 156
milliards d'euros de dettes sociales à
la Cadès afin de reprendre le déficit
cumulé depuis 2020 liée à la crise
sanitaire en 2022 c'est transferts se
sont poursuivis à hauteur de 40 millions
d'euros nous ne prévoyons pas de
nouvelles lois sur le sujet à ce stade
pour vous répondre madame la rapporteur
général vous m'avez demandé ce qui se
passerait s'il a loi de programmation
des finances publiques n'était pas
adoptée
ce sera un mauvais signal envoyer
tous les pays européens se dotent d'une
loi de programmation des finances
publiques
c'est important d'être capable de
prévoir d'avoir de la visibilité sur la
progression de nos dépenses c'est aussi
un enjeu de bonne gestion on peut avoir
des désaccords sur évidemment des points
de la politique qui est menée c'est même
heureux et sain en démocratie qu'on est
désaccord enfin le fait de ne pas avoir
de programmation des finances publiques
sur les trois ou cinq prochaines années
objectivement c'est un problème on va
pas se cacher derrière son petit doigt
sur la question des financements
européens c'est vrai qu'un certain
nombre de nos financements européens
sont conditionnés dans les engagements
qui ont été pris par l'ensemble des pays
européens à un certain nombre d'éléments
vous avez des financements qui sont
conditionnés au fait de disposer d'un
dispositif d'évaluation pérenne de la
qualité de la dépense publique c'est ce
qui est prévu dans la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
très concrètement si on n'a pas à ce
dispositif pérenne c'est un problème
alors est-ce qu'on peut trouver un moyen
via les
loi de finances chaque année de prévoir
pour l'année suivante un dispositif
d'évaluation de la qualité de la dépense
publique moi je regarde toutes les
possibilités parce que si on me dit que
j'ai pas de loi de programmation il faut
évidemment que je regarde les
alternatives ça fait partie des
possibilités est-ce que c'est
suffisamment robuste je suis pas sûr
ensuite vous avez d'autres crédits qui
pour le coup eux sont conditionnés à
l'adoption d'une loi de programmation
des finances publiques qui interviennent
plutôt en 2023 donc voilà moi mon
souhait c'est qu'on puisse avoir une loi
de programmation des finances publiques
votre solennel à l'Assemblée nationale a
lieu cet après-midi je comprends que
l'ensemble des oppositions fait le choix
de voter contre et donc ça laisse assez
peu de chances au texte d'être adopté à
l'Assemblée nationale et j'ai envie de
dire encore une fois nous
espérons beaucoup de la responsabilité
des sénatrices et des sénateurs pour
être capable d'adopter un texte qui nous
permettra ensuite de cheminer pardon je
crois que je suis trop long dans mes
réponses mais
c'était important d'être clair sur le
transfert des IJ poste natale de la
branche maladie à la branche famille
c'est pas une ponction en fait une
ponction ça serait prendre faire de la
tuyauterie prendre une recette qui
affectée à la branche famille et puis la
bouger vers la branche maladie ça serait
retiré brutalement des recettes à la
branche famille au profit de la branche
maladie là on transfère un certain
nombre de dépenses de la branche maladie
à la branche famille en cohérence avec
des dépenses déjà réalisées par la
branche fun la branche famille assume
aujourd'hui les IJ paternité donc les IJ
maternité post-natale une fois que
l'enfant est né par cohérence
selon nous peuvent être prises en charge
par la branche famille on parle des IJ
post-natales et en cohérence je crois
que la commission des affaires sociales
de l'Assemblée nationale a adopté un
amendement qui prévoit le transfert des
IJ adoption à la branche famille là
aussi en pleine cohérence mais on ne
prévoit pas de nouvelles mesures de ce
type dans les années à venir pour nous
c'est une mesure de cohérence avant
d'être une mesure
financière sur la fiscalité du tabac
vous demandiez l'objectif l'objectif
évidemment que l'on partage tous je
pense sur tous les bancs c'est de faire
en sorte de faire reculer la prévalence
du tabagisme dans notre pays et c'est
vrai que le signal prix là-dessus
fonctionne on a vu dans le quinquennat
précédent le président de la République
s'était engagé dans sa campagne en 2017
sur une trajectoire tabac pour porter le
paquet à 10 euros le paquet a été porté
à 10 euros et entre dans le quinquennat
qui vient de s'écouler la prévalence du
tabagisme a reculé de trois points dans
notre pays selon les données de santé
publique France c'est donc une
estimation de 2 millions de nos
concitoyens qui auraient arrêter de
fumée donc on voit que ça un impact il
faut aussi continuer à faire la
prévention on a beaucoup investi aussi
sur ce sujet là le sens de la mesure qui
est proposé dans le PLFSS
moi j'appellerai pas ça une mesure de
rendement parce que de toute façon le
tabac nous coûte plus cher qui ne nous
rapporte moi je veux vraiment aussi
mettre un peu fin à cette fiction qui
consiste à dire que l'État s'enrichit
grâce au tabac dans notre pays non les
recettes fiscales liées au tabac ou la
sécurité sociale les recettes les
recettes liées au tabac c'est autour de
14 milliards d'euros par an c'est ça les
dépenses directes liées au tabagisme
c'est 26 milliards d'euros par an
dépense direct chaque année donc on voit
bien que ce que nous rapporte la
fiscalité sur le tabac est très loin de
ce que nous coûte le tabagisme dans
notre pays le sens de cette mesure c'est
pas de rapporter de l'argent c'est pas
de relancer une trajectoire fiscale
c'est de faire en sorte que les efforts
qui ont été faits ces dernières années
ne soient pas anniées par l'inflation
puisque comme vous aviez un système de
revalorisation du prix du tabac par
droit d'accès qui prévoyait que le prix
du paquet était revalorisé de
l'inflation non pas de l'année
précédente mais il y a deux ans et capé
à
1,8%, ça fait qu'avec le l'inflation
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui dans notre
pays le prix rel du paquet de cigarettes
finit par baisser par rapport aux autres
produits de consommation ce qui est pas
notre objectif et les Français ont fait
beaucoup d'efforts les buralistes ont
fait beaucoup d'efforts aussi il s'agit
pas que ces efforts soient gâchés
maintenant pour la suite évidemment
notre objectif c'est de réduire la
consommation de tabac dans notre pays
n'est pas prévu aujourd'hui de nouvelles
trajectoires fiscales sur le tabac moi
il y a un point sur lequel je suis très
attentif aussi c'est de faire reculer la
contrebande et les trafics de tabac dans
notre pays parce que la réalité c'est
qu'on peut augmenter les prix
indéfiniment si vous avez des trafics
qui explosent dans notre pays vous
augmentez les prix donc sa fragilise
aussi un réseau de buralistes mais on a
beaucoup agi pour sa diversification en
développant de nouvelles activités
aujourd'hui ils peuvent encaisser des
amendes des factures du quotidien vendre
un certain nombre de produits mais pour
finalement une consommation qui se
réduit moins puisque elle s'alimente via
un marché parallèle et donc je prépare
actuellement un nouveau plan tabac un
nouveau plan de lutte contre les trafics
qui devraient que nous devrions
présenter d'ici à la fin de l'année on
saisit de plus en plus de cigarettes et
de trafic ce qui veut dire que nos
services et notamment nos douanes à qui
je veux fromage sont très efficaces
enfin ce qui veut aussi dire que les
trafics augmentent cachés derrière mon
petit doigt en disant que si on saisit
plus c'est juste parce qu'on est plus
efficace c'est aussi parce que les
trafics augmentent on démantèle même
maintenant en France ça nous est arrivé
à deux reprises des usines de
fabrication de de cigarettes clandestine
qu'on en a des mantes les deux donc il y
a cet enjeu majeur qui passe aussi par
une harmonisation fiscale au niveau
européen auquel je pense on doit
s'attaquer attaquer avant de réfléchir à
une nouvelle trajectoire fiscale en tout
cas c'est ma conviction sur les
questions de Madame Humbert portée par
Monsieur
mouillé sur l'ONDAM moi je veux insister
sur le fait que en 2025 2026 l'ONDA m'a
progressé plus vite que l'inflation
prévoit 2,1 et 1 75% d'inflation entre
2,7 et 2,6% pour Londres moi vraiment je
pour avoir participé j'étais pas
parlementaire à l'époque mais aucun
cadenas de François Hollande dans un
ministère qui est le ministère de la
Santé donc j'ai pas mal suivi les
questions de santé et les questions
d'hondables je vois assez mal comment on
peut aujourd'hui qualifier notre
politique de santé et la dame de petites
d'austérité enfin je veux dire les
chiffres qui sont avancés aujourd'hui
les investissements qu'on réalise on en
aurait rêvé à l'époque où les
socialistes qui avaient pour objectif de
défendre l'hôpital public et le système
de santé était au pouvoir et c'est pas
une remise en cause de la ministre de
l'époque que j'ai fidèlement et
loyalement en service et des choix
politiques du président de la République
et du Premier ministre et des premiers
ministres de l'époque qui n'étaient pas
ceux d'en investissement massif dans nos
dépenses de santé quand on a un mandat
hospitalier à 4,1% alors que c'était 2%
en moyenne sous le quinquennat François
Hollande on voit que c'est un
investissement massif sur le grand âge
c'était 1% en moyenne à l'époque en
moyenne annuelle c'est 5,1% l'an
prochain j'entends qu'il faut faire plus
mais enfin il y a un investissement
massif qui est là et oui ça n'exonère
pas de faire des efforts sur un certain
nombre de sujets il y a des leviers
d'économie dans ce PLFSS que j'ai
rappelé on va continuer à investir sur
la prévention sur la pertinence des
soins sur la maîtrise médicalisée ça
sera évidemment notamment en ville ça
sera ça sera évidemment notre objectif
dans les années à venir j'essaye
d'accélérer parce que je comprends que
là aussi je suis trop long sur pardon
les moyens alloués aux EHPAD moi je veux
rappeler les moyens importants à louer
ces dernières années 500 millions
d'euros qui ont été attribués entre 2017
et 2021 pour renforcer la médicalisation
des EHPAD ça permet de financement de 20
000 postes de personnels soignants
supplémentaires on ne va pas s'arrêter
là puisque nous nous sommes engagés dans
le cadre de la campagne présidentielle à
la création de 50000 postes
supplémentaires dans les EHPAD pas
franchir une première mâche cette année
avec
170 millions d'euros qui sont prévus
pour financer 3000 ETP et pour augmenter
le taux d'encadrement et faire face à
l'accroissement des pas besoin en soins
des résidents des EHPAD 50 millions
d'euros pour faire basculer 200 EHPAD au
tarif global qui permet de salariés plus
de médecins et de soignants et près de
60 millions d'euros pour créer des
places des pâtes dans 10 millions
d'euros pour enclencher un plan de
rattrapage EHPAD en outre-mer mais je
suis conscient de la nécessité de
renforcer l'attractivité des métiers
c'est aussi un enjeu très fort c'est
pourquoi 3,2 milliards d'euros ont été
alloués au secteur des personnes âgées
depuis 2020 je le disais
tout à l'heure sur la question des eigy
maternité postnatale j'ai répondu à la
rapporteur général monsieur Hainaut et
donc je vous confirme qu'on va continuer
à agir et investir pour la politique
familiale dans notre pays qui n'est pas
prévu aujourd'hui d'autres mesures du
type que celles que nous portons dans ce
PLFSS mais qui est encore une fois est
avant tout une mesure de cohérence
merci
Chantal de Seine va poser les questions
de René Paul Savary je crois sur la
branche vieillesse ensuite nous aurons
une deux trois quatre
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre finalement le gouvernement a
rejoint les positions de la Mecque au
sujet des transfert aux URSSAF de
l'activité de recouvrement de
l'agriculture
c'est très bien vous le repoussez en
2024 toutefois pouvez-vous vous engager
devant nous à ce que argot conserve une
fois le transfert de recouvrement
réalisé la responsabilité de la
fiabilisation des DSN émise par les
employeurs et ses affiliés une deuxième
question dans le cas où vous nous
confirmez la conservation par l'Égypte
Arrco de son activité de fiabilisation
ce qui nous paraît tout à fait
indispensable pourquoi le PLFSS
prévoit-il de réserver au seul organisme
de sécurité sociale à l'exclusion
notamment de l'agile cargo l'émission
d'une DSN de substitution dans le cas où
l'employeur ne procéderait pas aux
corrections des anomalies détectées et
la troisième une question rapidement
comment justifier vous le transfert aux
urssafs par simple amendement sans
études d'impact ni examen préalable du
recouvrement des cotisations des
cotisations APEC et des cotisations des
expatriés recouvrez jusqu'ici
respectivement par l'agit argot et par
Malakoff Humanis
alors ça ce sera jerco Daniel Chassin
Bernard Chaumier Nadia sur le groupe et
Monique lubinet
de nous avoir bien expliqué le PLFSS
vous avez parlé de l'ONDAM effectivement
qui a augmenté de
4,1%, c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup
mieux que 2% entre 2012 et 2017 mais
c'est vrai que il faut tempérer parce
que l'inflation comme vous l'avez dit ça
pas un impact sur tout mais c'est quand
même un impact important
et aussi bien sûr il faut des
cotisations pour avoir des recettes au
niveau de la sécurité sociale et c'est
vrai que on a quand même dans une
turbulence avec l'Allemagne qui a les
moyens de soutenir ces entreprises et
nous beaucoup moins ce qui fait qu'elle
soit on risque d'être moins compétitive
et on risque d'aller vers des
difficultés de l'emploi donc je poserai
deux questions la première
concernant le ministre donc monsieur
Brown qui dit qu'il faut mobiliser les
médecins et notamment le cumul emploi
retraite alors il y a des médecins qui
ont pas envie de s'inscrire à la caisse
de retraite des médecins français à ce
moment-là ils peuvent s'inscrire à la
surface à l'URSSAF mais ils peuvent pas
voir plus de 19000 € de chiffre
d'affaires est-ce que ça pourrait pas
être augmenté et enfin les médecins qui
cotisent à l'arcane c'est à fond perdu
donc ils n'auront pas d'augmentation de
leur retraite ce que c'est pas possible
à ce niveau là de faire aussi un effort
et enfin au niveau du médico-social vous
avez dit que il allait avoir une
augmentation il y a une augmentation de
5,1% et qu'on n'est pas au bout du
chemin c'est vrai
parce que dans les EHPAD on a des
personnes très dépendantes et tout le
monde la population
les employés attendent une augmentation
du nombre d'emploi vous avez dit 50 000
cette année c'est 3000 c'est-à-dire que
ça fait un demi emplois par EHPAD
puisqu'il y a 7500 EHPAD donc est-ce que
vous allez avoir un plan
pluriannuel le plus rapide possible pour
créer ces 50000 emplois je peux
comprendre effectivement que il y a eu
le covid il y a la guerre en Ukraine ça
c'est d'accord et aussi des créations
d'emplois en EHPAD et aussi les oubliés
du Ségur il y en a encore qu'il faut
prendre en compte merci Bernard Chaumier
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le ministre pour pour votre
exposé puis vos premières réponses
il persiste quand même que les
hypothèses macroéconomiques défendues
par le gouvernement sont son optimiste
alors bon c'est de bonne guerre vous
avez vous avez une longue pratique de ce
type de position mais
vous nous avez parlé de 2026 en nous
disant en 2026 on sera au dessus du taux
de progression l'inflation 2026 c'est
dans trois quatre ans en 2019 qui
pouvait penser que l'inflation c'est
aujourd'hui à 6%. donc si vous voulez
les hypothèses sur 2025 2026 très bien
mais elles sont faits pour être
démenties par l'effet par contre on
délibère la sur 2023 et le ministre de
l'Économie
disait récemment que l'inflation serait
à 5% à peu près début 2023 et autour de
4 à la fin de l'année bon l'hypothèse
aussi relativement op existe on va dire
en tout état de cause tous les chiffres
que vous affichez sont inférieurs à ces
projections d'inflation et l'exposition
des établissements de santé dans leur
structure de dépenses à l'inflation
personne n'a pu moi tout ce que j'ai
interrogé et fédération compris
différentes fédérations n'indiquent
qu'il serait sous-exposés à l'inflation
donc je veux bien qu'on présente les
choses de la façon la plus séduisante et
vous manquez pas de capacité en la
matière quand vous dites jamais on a
consacré autant d'argent à l'hôpital oui
on ne recourant mais on ne reconstant
c'est pas vrai ou dit autrement tous vos
prédécesseurs auraient pu dire oui cette
année on donne plus d'argent que l'année
suivante à l'hôpital puisque d'année en
année ça augmente quand même même quand
la vie c'était est très était très
serrée donc au-delà de ses effets on est
dans un budget qui est extrêmement
contraint et plusieurs collègues l'ont
soulign on voit mal comment il va
s'appliquer dans ces conditions là alors
j'ai deux trois questions la première
sur les recettes
on est passé
en 2018 sur les exonérations de
cotisation donc des recettes qui font
défaut parfois d'ailleurs au bénéfice de
l'activité économique je mets pas en
cause le principe général mais on est
passé à un peu moins de 40 milliards
d'exonérations et en 2023 on arrive à 71
milliards estimez-vous que l'ensemble de
ces exonérations
voilà ne doit pas être discuté ou qu'il
y a matière à
on va dire étudier de près le détail de
ces exonérations pour éventuellement y
mettre fin à certaines d'entre elles la
deuxième question porte sur l'hôpital
donc vous affichez 4,1% donc si ce sera
inférieur à l'inflation en 2023 de
progression du budget hospitalier
la situation de l'hôpital
on la connaît tous ces jours derniers
c'est la pédiatrie qui fait l'actualité
avec des propos des pédiatres qui sont
particulièrement inquiétants
les expressions comme le tri
refond surface et sont argumentés
notamment par un texte qui a été signé
par plusieurs milliers de soignants en
pédiatrie le président de la CME de la
PHP qui est pédiatre lui-même alerte et
d'ailleurs il faut donner acte que le
ministre de la Santé avec le
gouvernement a réagi en annonçant
immédiatement une enveloppe de 150
millions alors pas uniquement pour la
pédiatrie bon et ma question c'est que
on n'est pas encore au début de
l'application de ce budget qu'on voit
déjà que ça ne va pas qui n'est pas
suffisant dans le rapport de la
commission enquête sur l'hôpital public
rapporté par Catherine de roche
une mesure essentielle a été pointée la
nécessité de revaloriser le travail de
nuit et de week-end que nous disent les
pédiatres que saint des facteurs majeurs
de fuite des soignants hors de la
pédiatrie or aucune mesure n'a toujours
été prise sur cette question moi j'ai
été surpris en lisant le PLFSS
de trouver en fait hormis l'inertie de
l'application des mesures Ségur aucune
mesure en faveur de l'hôpital public
aucune
voilà et donc est-ce que vous estimez
que c'est tenable et pouvez-vous nous
préciser à ce jour je n'ai peut-être pas
encore décidé mais quelle disposition
vont être prises sur la question de
l'énergie on a vu les annonces
concernant les PME faites par le
gouvernement mais concernant les
établissements hospitaliers il n'y a pas
eu pour le moment de dispositif annoncé
or l'impact risque d'être très important
voilà bon je vais m'en tenir là pour les
questions et juste dire à la rapporteur
général qu'elle peut compter sur nous
pour l'alcool ça arrivera
c'est toujours un débat très animé ça va
alcool et chasse à la mon dieu
la chasse aux dépenses inutiles quand
même moi dans mon département j'ai eu
trois chasseurs qui ont été dans trois
personnes qui faisaient du vélo qui se
sont pris des plans le weekend dernier
donc ça ça bouge Nadia c'est le coup oui
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre où nous annoncer à un PLFSS
plus juste or vous annoncez en même
temps que pour les arrêts maladie
prescrit en téléconsultation les
patients qui n'ont pas dont l'arrêt
maladie n'est pas prescrit par un
médecin traitant ou un médecin qui
aurait été consulté dans les 12 derniers
mois ils seront pas remboursés alors moi
je suis élue dans un territoire où
beaucoup de patients ne se trouvent pas
de médecin traitant et je pense que
cette mesure pourrait être vécue comme
une très grosse injustice et très mal
être très mal perçue le ministre Braun à
qui j'ai posé la même question disait
que finalement les patients qui ont un
arrêt maladie et qui n'ont pas de
médecin 18 ans représente une part
finalement relativement modeste alors si
ces modèles c'est donc si c'est pas trop
cher je pense qu'il faudrait quand même
lâcher là dessus au moins pour les
patients qui n'ont pas de médecin
traitant deuxième sujet qui n'a rien à
voir vous je vais pas vous apprendre
qu'on a un enjeu très fort sur la
formation des médecins et vous le numéro
clausus a été supprimé cependant il nous
faut des preuves de médecine j'ai eu la
chance d'insister récemment un coloc à
l'Académie de médecine où il était fait
un constat consternant sur le nombre de
d'enseignants-chercheurs qui démissionne
de leur chair non seulement nous
manquons de professeurs de médecine mais
en plus il y en a qui nous reste pas et
le motif en éclair il manque de moyens
pour mener leurs travaux alors au cours
des débats ils ont fait état du fait que
c'était pas très clair finalement de de
connaître les moyens qui étaient
affectés à la recherche en médecine
parce que les budgets sont dilués sur
différents postes budgétaires et on s'y
retrouve pas très bien et eux ils disent
qu'ils ont beaucoup de mal à accéder à
est assez budget donc il y a un enjeu
très fort sur les enseignants les
enseignants en médecine et je vous
demande vraiment de d'être attentif à ce
sujet
Monique Lubin
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre moi je l'avais pas prévu
d'intervenir mais je dois dire que votre
rhétorique en matière de retraite est
extraordinaire et donc je peux pas
m'empêcher finalement de dire deux mots
parce que quand vous nous dites par
exemple que il est prouvé que le fait de
repousser l'âge de la retraite
améliore les statistiques en matière
d'emploi des seniors c'est une
lapalissade évidemment plus plus en
retard de l'âge de la retraite plus les
10 seniors sont au travail puisqu'on
leur permet pas de partir à la retraite
quand vous dites que l'emploi des
seniors justement c'est considérablement
amélioré nous avons commis avec René
Paul Savary un rapport c'était en 2018
je crois
je vois pas bien ce qui s'est passé
depuis très honnêtement je ne vois pas
mais même du tout ce qui s'est passé
depuis ensuite vous justifiez le report
de nage de la retraite pour pour
expliquer que plus il y a de gens qui
travaille plus il y a de cotisations
sociales et donc mieux c'est pour les
comptes sociaux du pays ça aussi c'est
évident mais alors pourquoi au lieu de
d'obliger les gens à travailler plus
longtemps pour avoir de meilleurs
rentrées fiscales et sociales pourquoi
quand continuez-vous à désocialiser tout
ce qui peut être des socialisé la
moindre crise et j'ai envie de dire la
moindre le moindre la moindre bonne
raison ce sont des bonnes raisons je
reviens pas dessus pour créer des
emplois et ainsi de suite vous vous
autorise à désocialiser toujours au
maximum et on contrepartie on va
expliquer à des gens qui travaillent
pour la plupart depuis plus de 40 ans
que eux vont devoir continuer à
travailler pour qu'il y ait plus de
rentrée sociale et fiscale dans les
caisses de l'étage je vous avoue que là
franchement je termine comme j'ai
commencé bravo pour la rhétorique
très bien Corinne Amber souhaite est
arrivé et peut-être complété par rapport
aux questions de Philippe merci la
présidente excusez-moi mon retard
monsieur le ministre juste une question
j'espère que vous les jugerez pas
impertinentes mais dans la suite des
propos de notre collègue
Bernard Chaumier dans à la hauteur
assemblée il y a quatre ans je crois 4,5
ans n'a été un petit peu échaudé par une
annonce de 300 millions d'euros en
faveur de l'hôpital à la veille de de
l'ouverture du début de la discussion
générale et de l'examen du PLFSS là on
est à 15 jours de l'ouverture des débats
ici et personne ne conteste les besoins
pour la pédiatrie mais 150 millions
annoncés dimanche en faveur des urgences
pédiatriques juste d'où viennent les 150
millions voilà s'il vous plaît c'est une
goutte d'eau par rapport au milliards et
au budget important mais vous voyez il y
a 4 ans nous avons été un peu échaudés
je trouve sur la méthode c'était en
cours d'examen voilà et donc là je serai
intéressé pour vous expliquer d'où ça
vient
on a 15 jours
on a encore 15 jours pour que la somme
évolue
je vais démarrer non pas par Madame de
scène qui relayait les questions de
Monsieur Savary mais par une question de
Madame Imbert qu'elle a posé sans être
là puisqu'elle était portée par Monsieur
mouillé c'est ça
à laquelle je n'ai pas répondu tout à
l'heure sur les sur les la mise en
réserve de London
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques elle prévoyait déjà durant le
quinquennat précédent une mise en
réserve de 0,3% par an ça représente
environ 700 millions d'euros sur London
c'est moins que sur le budget de l'État
on est entre 0,4 et 0,5 % selon les
types de dépenses et je pense que chacun
comprend qu'il faut prévoir une marge
d'ajustement au cours de gestion afin de
respecter les objectifs votés par les
parlementaires hors événement majeur
comme une crise sanitaire telle que
celle qu'on a vécu bien entendu
on a des travaux en cours sur la manière
de répartir cette mise en réserve
traditionnellement c'est vrai que
l'essentiel effectivement imputé sur le
coefficient tu prudentiel des tarifs
hospitaliers mais nous souhaitons mieux
répartir cet effort et on y travaille
avec mon collègue François Braun et mon
collègue Jean-Christophe combe par
ailleurs c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la
médecine de ville est entre guillemets
exonéré de cette mise en réserve il faut
voir comment est-ce qu'on peut trouver
un mécanisme qui permet de partager
entre guillemets la charge de cette
réserve mais j'avais pas répondu
effectivement à la question tout à
l'heure sur les questions relatives à
l'agir que Arrco donc c'est les
questions de Monsieur Savary porter par
Madame de scène oui je vous le dis et le
réaffirme la fiabilisation des données
individuelles des salariés des restera
la prérogative de la JR
l'amendement prévoit qu'une convention
soit signée entre la jaccargo et lacos
sur ce sujet je serais très attentif
évidemment à ce que ce soit bien prévu
et bien écrit sur les cotisations APEC
et expatriés c'est un transfert qui est
corrélé à celui des retraites
complémentaires et qui donc est lui
aussi décalé à
2024 moi je veux vraiment insister sur
deux choses d'abord c'est qu'avec cet
amendement on répond au revendications
des partenaires sociaux de la CFDT du
Medef au revendications
préconisations du rapport sénatorial
produit par cette commission sur le
sujet et la deuxième chose sur laquelle
je veux insister c'est que j'attends
désormais une coopération loyale entre
l'agirco et la cosse
et je pense qu'il faut désormais que
chacun soit au rendez-vous de ses
responsabilités pour faire en sorte que
ce transfert soit un succès c'est un
message qui est passé de manière très
claire et que je continuerai à passer
sur les questions de Monsieur Chassin
sur le cumul emploi retraite aujourd'hui
ce que nous dit l'adresse c'est que 47%
des médecins ont plus de 55 ans et 30%
plus de 60 ans le nombre de nos
concitoyens n'ayant pas accès à un
médecin traitant risque donc d'augmenter
si on dégage pas rapidement du temps
médical supplémentaire on a pris des
mesures importantes et notamment la
suppression du numérus clausus on forme
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus de médecins
chaque année mais ça va mettre un peu de
temps évidemment à se voir sur le
terrain la question c'est comment est-ce
qu'on fait le pont et comment est-ce
qu'on arrive à prendre des mesures
utiles d'ici à ce que on est plus de
médecins qui arrivent sur le terrain
grâce aux mesures qu'on a prises au
début du précédent quinquennat d'où ce
qu'on a porté sur la télémédecine 12
qu'on doit porter aussi sur la question
du cumul emploi retraite il faut
encourager les médecins libéraux à
rester en activité et même je le dis
faire revenir certains retraités qui
peuvent exercer et donc il y a un
amendement qui est exonère pendant un an
les médecins de cotisation vieillesse
c'est la reconduction d'une mesure qui a
montré son son efficacité lors de la
crise sanitaire pour envoyer un signal
fort ou médecin retraités ou proche de
la retraite je dis il s'agit d'une
mesure d'urgence pour agir contre les
déserts médicaux raison pour laquelle
elle est reconduite régulièrement mais
qui est importante sur les oubliés du
Ségur le choix qu'on a fait ça a été de
cibler l'extension des accords du Ségur
sur les soignants d'une part et sur les
professionnels qui exercent à titre
principal des fonctions d'accompagnement
sociaux éducatives d'autre part ce sont
les métiers qui sont le plus soumis aux
difficultés fortes de recrutement il
était donc essentiel de renforcer
l'attractivité pour préserver la qualité
de prise en charge des personnes
accueillies ou prises en charge c'est la
raison pour ça et pour laquelle les
personnels techniques administ ne sont
pas prioritairement concernés et je
rappelle par ailleurs que l'accord du 2
mai 2022 reprend strictement les termes
de la conférence des métiers de
l'accompagnement social et médico-social
18 février 2022 qui a fait l'objet d'une
concertation avec l'adnf l'Assemblée des
départements de France ils visent des
catégories d'établissement et services
sociaux et médico-sociaux listés dans le
code de l'action sociale et des familles
et non pas de l'ensemble des
professionnels de la sphère de l'action
sociale
moi je veux dire que le champ de
l'accompagnement sociaux éducatif je
vais pas vous apprendre quelque chose
c'est très difficile à circonscrire
c'est très difficile à définir
précisément mais on travaille on
continue de travailler à la
revalorisation de certains
professionnels notamment dans le domaine
de la petite enfance avec le comité de
filière il y avait ensuite les questions
de Monsieur jaumier sur la question de
l'inflation
pour prévoir les budgets dédiés à la
prise en charge de l'inflation pour les
établissements de santé on a travaillé
avec les fédérations notamment les
fédérations hospitalières elles ont
globalement chiffrées les besoins sur
2022 et sur 2023 entre 700 millions et 1
milliard 100 millions d'euros le PLFSS
que vous avez voté pour 2022 ou plutôt
la LSS qui a été adoptée pour 2022
prévoyez déjà je crois entre 100 et 200
millions d'euros au titre de l'impact de
l'inflation ce qu'on prévoit dans la
partie rectificative du PLFSS pour 2022
c'est 800 millions d'euros
supplémentaires sur 2022 donc on est
autour d'un milliard d'euros dédié à
l'inflation sur 2022 et on prévoit 800
milliards 800 millions d'euros
supplémentaires en 2023 moi je vais
insister sur le fait que j'entends
encore une fois c'est comparaisons entre
l'ONDAM et l'inflation mais je le redis
l'inflation n'a pas un impact uniforme
sur l'ensemble des dépenses de santé
elle a principalement un impact sur les
achats hospitaliers les coûts de
l'énergie c'est une assiette de 20 à 25
milliards d'euros de dépenses je dis pas
que c'est rien c'est évidemment
important enfin c'est pas l'intégralité
de nos dépenses de santé c'est pas les
250 milliards d'euros 244 milliards
d'euros de dépenses sous une dame donc
il faut prendre les mesures qui
répondent aux besoins des établissements
en l'occurrence c'est ce que nous
faisons avec cette partie rectificative
j'espère que le Sénat l'adoptera puisque
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale a
rejeté la partie rectificative du plfs
pour 2022 et donc les 800 millions
d'euros supplémentaires pour l'hôpital
public comme dommage donc on espère que
ça sera adopté au Sénat ils ont par
ailleurs rejeté aussi les certifications
des comptes 2021 ce qui est sans grand
effet mais ce qui traduit je trouve
quand même une volonté de de tout
bloquer
sur les autres questions de Monsieur
jaumier notamment sur les exonérations
de cotisation les bases de cotisations
c'est vrai qu'elles ont un sens c'est de
favoriser l'emploi dans notre pays et la
compétitivité de nos entreprises et le
fait que ça coûte moins cher d'employés
et d'embaucher si on avait eu une
explosion du chômage j'entends faudrait
les critiques sur ce choix-là le fait
était qu'on a le chômage le plus bas
depuis 15 ans le taux de chômage des
jeunes le plus bas depuis 40 ans le taux
d'emploi le plus haut depuis qu'il est
mesuré je pense pas que ça soit le fruit
du hasard ou de la magie c'est le fruit
d'une cohérence dans une politique
fiscale et sociale qui vise à faire
baisser la pression fiscale et sociale
sur nos entreprises pour qu'elles
puissent embaucher ensuite vous dites
est-ce que vous considérez qu'on a le
droit de s'interroger ou de regarder y
compris sur certains allègements
évidemment enfin je veux dire moi je
pense que c'est sain et d'ailleurs dans
l'alpf je réponds avec retard à une
partie de la question de Madame douanot
dans l'alpfp on prévoit des dispositifs
qui renforcent et qui encadrent
davantage nos exonérations sociales et
fiscales pour les entreprises et les
dispositifs d'aide aux entreprises il y
a maintenant une obligation de les
évaluer au bout de trois ans pour
pouvoir ensuite les reconduire ou non
donc on encadre davantage c'est aussi
pour ça que la LPF elle est utile parce
qu'en matière de gouvernance des
finances publiques elle fixe un cadre
beaucoup plus strict et je crois par
ailleurs un rôle du Parlement renforcé
dans ce type d'exonération moi je pense
qu'à partir du moment on engage l'argent
des Français en tout cas on se prive de
recettes
pour nos finances publiques ou notre
sécurité sociale c'est important que ça
soit évalué par les parlementaires et
qu'on doit
s'impose de décider de les reconduire ou
non si c'est utile en matière d'emploi
donc oui évidemment très ouvert à des
études et des propositions sur ce sujet
là sur la question de l'hôpital et du
des mesures qui ont été annoncées et du
budget supplémentaire lié à la crise que
nous avons en pédiatrie c'est vrai que
nous sommes
très vigilant sur ce sujet là et
préoccupé ça renvoie aussi aux mesures
qu'on a prises au début du dernier qu'un
Sénat quinquennat l'objectif c'est
d'avoir davantage de pédiatre dans nos
hôpitaux ça prend un peu de temps mais
évidemment ça nécessite dans une crise
telle que celle qu'on connaît de prendre
des mesures d'urgence donc il y a les
150 millions d'euros qui ont été
annoncés on a un travail en ce moment
interministériel conduit avec Matignon
pour vous éclairer sur la source de ces
150 millions d'euros supplémentaires ce
sera le cas d'ici l'examen au Sénat
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas eu vraiment à
préciser ça à l'Assemblée nationale
puisque comme ils ont rejeté en bloc la
partie rectificative de la dame 2022
finalement ça écourté les débats mais je
sais que Sénat nous aurons des débats
nourris sur ce sujet là et donc nous
allons évidemment préparer l'examen du
texte avec la plus grande célérité
aucune mesure en faveur de l'hôpital
public bon je dirais pas ça ne serait-ce
que parce que l'ONDAM et les dépenses
qui sont prévues financent des mesures
massives qui ont été prises avec le
Ségur de la santé qui est quand même un
socle qui a largement qui s'est
largement
amplifié sur
l'énergie pour des établissements de
santé c'est les mesures et les budgets
supplémentaires qu'on a prévu pour
l'inflation madame sologo sur la
question des téléconsultations je veux
vraiment rappeler qu'il s'agit de
réguler on parle d'un pour cent des
arrêts maladie
1% des arrêts vous dites justement c'est
peu donc est-ce qu'il faut le réguler ça
double chaque année ça double chaque
année alors ça reste peu mais en
dynamique on voit qu'il y a une
croissance très forte la question qu'on
doit se poser c'est à qui est dû cette
croissance
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu entendre
et si vous là c'est pas des habitants de
territoires ruraux qui seraient privés
d'un accès à un médecin généraliste ou
un médecin traitant à 80 ou 90% c'est
des habitants en zone urbaine et un
autre fait qui est intéressant c'est que
pour ces arrêts maladie prescrit en
téléconsultation qui ne viennent pas du
médecin traitant qu'est-ce qu'on
constate
c'est une minorité de ces arrêts maladie
donne lieu à une prescription de
médicaments ou de soins
par rapport à des arrêts maladie
classiques qui eux en grande majorité
donne lieu à des prescriptions de
médicaments ou de soins et donc
objectivement ce qu'on chasse c'est tout
simplement des personnes qui font une
forme de nomadisme numérique jusqu'à
trouver un professionnel de santé qui
acceptera en visioconférence de lui
délivrer un arrêt maladie il y a des
articles qui ont été produits après que
j'ai fait cette annonce j'envoie
notamment un article du Parisien une
journaliste qui attitré son papier
comment je me suis fait préférer un
arrêt maladie en deux minutes sur
Internet voilà
c'est évidemment pas un phénomène majeur
en termes de volume mais on fait en
termes de dynamique ça double chaque
année depuis deux ans donc moi je
préfère qu'on régule un certain nombre
de choses en amont quand c'est encore
marginal plutôt qu'on se pose la
question des années après en disant vous
avez laissé ce phénomène s'amplifier
vous avez rien fait voilà maintenant ce
qu'on a prévu de faire par ailleurs
c'est des mesures d'accompagnement de
meilleures informations de mobilisation
des plateformes évidemment pour pas que
ça coupe l'accès à des arrêts maladie
pour des personnes qui en ont besoin
mais aujourd'hui dans les bénéficiaires
on constate que c'est pas des personnes
qui sont dans des déserts médicaux et
qui n'arrivent pas à trouver un médecin
c'est plutôt des gens qui se disent que
leur médecin traitant n'acceptera pas de
leur faire un arrêt maladie aussi
facilement qu'il le souhaiterait voilà
je dis des choses caches
sur la question des professeurs de
médecine là il faut vraiment regarder le
budget des universités et des organismes
de recherche notamment de l'Inserm qui
augmente il y a une loi de programmation
pluriannuelle sur la recherche qui est
extrêmement ambitieuse 25 milliards
d'euros sur 10 ans en plus évidemment il
faut continuer à aller plus loin j'y
travaille avec ma collègue Sylvie
Retailleau j'en profite pour préciser
c'est pas l'objet immédiat de nos
discussions sur le PLFSS mais qu'on
travaille à des ouvertures de crédit en
PLF de fin de gestion pour nos
universités notamment pour faire face à
l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie et
à la question de l'inflation même si on
sait que et je le dis aussi pour les
hôpitaux par rapport à ce que disait
monsieur jaumier le cœur de la
mobilisation ça doit être de faire
baisser le prix sur le marché de
l'énergie au niveau européen parce que
la réalité c'est que si on a un prix qui
continue à exploser et qu'on a des
prévisions totalement délirantes qui se
réalisent on peut se raconter tout ce
qu'on veut l'État ou la sécurité sociale
ne pourra pas compenser l'augmentation
des coûts pour l'ensemble des hôpitaux
l'ensemble des entreprises ou l'ensemble
des collectivités locales c'est pas vrai
de le dire donc le cœur la mobilisation
ça doit être de faire baisser les prix
et les mesures qui ont été trouvées au
Conseil européen en fin de semaine
dernière elle nous donne quand même de
l'espoir c'est un bouclier
antispéculation c'est une décorrélation
en tout cas un plafonnement du prix du
gaz pour produire l'électricité ça a eu
un impact immédiat sur les prix du gaz
sur les marchés après les annonces du
Conseil européen et l'objectif c'est que
ça a un impact sur les prix de
l'électricité il y a des précisions
techniques qui doivent intervenir mais
évidemment on va continuer à agir sur le
sujet c'était enfin Madame Lubin qui est
intervenu comptait pas intervenir et qui
a intervenu suite à mes propos j'en suis
ravi l'objectif que quand je viens c'est
qu'il y a du débat et qu'on puisse
échanger donc c'est c'est très bien
vous dites c'est une forme de la
palissade de dire que l'allongement de
la durée de travail en tout cas le recul
de l'âge légal entraîne une amélioration
du taux d'emploi je ne crois pas puisque
je trouve que dans le débat public on
entend beaucoup si vous reculez l'âge
légal vous n'allez pas entraîner des
travailleurs mais des chômeurs et on
procurer une forme de fatalité à ce que
des seniors qui pourraient partir à la
retraite un peu plus tard ce serait
condamné à être au chômage plutôt qu'à
travailler on entend beaucoup ça dans le
débat
or ce qu'on a constaté encore une fois
depuis la réforme de 2010 c'est qu'elle
s'est traduite par une amélioration du
taux d'emploi des seniors et la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il faut continuer à agir
pour l'emploi des seniors c'est une
certitude vous dites depuis le rapport
de 2018 rien n'a été fait un effort
massif en termes de formation quand même
avec le plan d'investissement dans les
compétences qui a été développé déployé
qui bénéficient beaucoup à des salariés
en fin de carrière pour des
reconversions je pense qu'il y a aussi
un changement culturel dans l'entreprise
et là aussi les rapports qui sont
produits peuvent y parvenir il y a des
grandes entreprises il y a des exemples
je suis pas là pour faire de la
publicité mais qui ont développé des
initiatives qui fonctionnent l'objectif
c'est d'arriver à les systématiser dans
le monde du travail mais évidemment que
ça fait partie des enjeux et que dans
les discussions qui sont menées
aujourd'hui par mon collègue du soft
avec les organisations syndicales la
question de l'emploi des seniors est un
enjeu absolument fondamental dans les
travaux qui sont menés voilà j'espère
avoir répondu à l'ensemble des questions
en tout cas au plus grand nombre d'entre
elles mais je suis ravi par avance de
vous retrouver au moment de l'examen du
texte en séance pour poursuivre nos
travaux
c'est Monsieur le Ministre pour
compléter jusqu'à 10 Bernard jaumier
concernant le Ségur et en effet les
effets dans le Ségur du Ségur sur les
comptes ça c'est indéniable lorsqu'on a
fait la commission d'enquête sur
l'hôpital le Ségur était déjà était déjà
défini en place moi ce que je trouve
dommage je l'ai dit je le répète ici
c'est que le Ségur qui a constitué en
effet un effort financier important
d'abord a été dans certains cas beaucoup
plus un rattrapage une vraie
revalorisation mais ça a été tellement
haché tellement fait semaine après
semaine on a passé notre temps à faire
des oubliés du Ségur enfin pas nous
le temps passé a été et ce qui fait
qu'au final tout le monde est mécontent
de mesure qu'il aurait dû normalement
améliorer les choses voilà je le dis
clairement et c'est vrai que des sujets
sur internet mais les besoins
hospitaliers sont il faut il faut
trouver des marges de manœuvre ailleurs
ça c'est évident sinon on laisse dériver
les comptes sociaux c'est pas l'objet
mais à un moment il faut quand même
regarder la situation telle qu'elle est
et il y a des besoins hospitaliers qui
ne sont pas qui ne sont pas en effet
définis dans dans ce PLFSS
à bientôt